[Music]
j.r.r tolkien's most famous works take
place
in the third age of middle earth and the
author has expanded on the history of
his legendarium elsewhere but what about
the years after the end of the war of
the reign
just what happened in middle earth's
fourth age
if you want to properly understand the
fourth age it's important to get a good
idea of what led up to it
the first stage begins when the dark
lord morgoth sneaks into the realm of
valinor
steals the one-of-a-kind jewels known as
the silmarils
and hightails it back to middle-earth
looking for revenge a faction of elves
set out in pursuit of their enemy
these elves spend the next 500 years
waiting war
against morgoth they win some early
victories but over time
the dark lord regains the initiative and
eventually utterly overwhelms the elves
and their mortal allies
the free peoples are only saved from
defeat when aragorn's ancestor
e arendelle sails back to the blessed
realm and asks the godlike valar for
help this leads to the catastrophic war
of wrath
in which morgoth is overthrown his
servants are scattered
and vast swaths of middle earth are
drowned beneath the sea
the second age is defined by a rise of a
new dark lord
morgos chief lieutenant sauron this age
is peaceful at first as the remaining
elves resettle in their new homes in the
eastern regions of middle earth
and men continue to populate the
continent off the coast some of these
men
found the island kingdom of numenor
eventually
sauron makes his return to middle earth
disguised as an elf named anatar
he helps the elves forge rings of power
and then creates his own ring in secret
to control them
when this backfires on sauron he
declares war on the elves and
redistributes most of the elvish rings
to races he can more easily control
one ring to rule them all
sauron nearly succeeds in conquering all
the middle earth but when he is
confronted by the full might of numenor
he willingly surrenders himself to them
sauron
however has a plan taken back to the
island nation
the dark lord corrupts its king and many
of its people
and eventually convinces them to invade
valinor
and take on the valar themselves this
goes pretty badly to say the least
and numenor itself is sunk beneath the
sea as a result
one faction of uncorrupted numenoreans
survives however
and settle two kingdoms on the mainland
gondor
and arnor when sauron arrives back when
the continent
and begins to stir up trouble again
these two kingdoms join forces with the
elves
together they march on mordor defeat
sauron's armies and cut the ring from
the dark lord's hand for the first
millennium of the third age
middle earth is at peace around a
thousand years into the third age
the valar send the five wizards to
middle earth to help
guide the free folk in their struggle
against evil
around the same time the forces of
sauron begin to muster
the kingdoms of gondor and arnor are
involved in a number of conflicts
over the ensuing years arnor is
eventually destroyed in a war
against the witch king and gondor loses
its own king
leading to the long rule of the stewards
the shire is
also founded about halfway through the
third age rohan is settled 900 years
later and after that
sauromon settles down in eisenguard and
starts to break bad
meanwhile the dwarves unleash the balrog
and moria
duke it out with the orcs of the misty
mountains and fight a war against
morgoth's dragons that eventually leads
to smaug
attacking the lonely mountain to top all
the drama
off the one ring is eventually
rediscovered leading to the war the ring
and the final destruction of sauron
the fourth age begins with the end of
the war of the ring
the specific date of the beginning of
the age is the source of some contention
but in the appendix to the return of the
king at least it's officially recorded
that this age begins when the keepers of
the three elven rings
that is elrond galadriel and gandalf
set sail for valinor this for the record
is september 29th of the 3021st year of
the third age
in a timeline tolkien provided in the
appendix to the return of the king he
writes
frodo and bilbo depart oversee with the
three keepers the
end of the third age with the departure
of the three rings from middle earth
the kingdoms of men find their true
place in the world
this new order is predicted by gandalf
and the return of the king
which he tells the ancient ant tree
beard
the new age begins and in this age it
may well prove
that the kingdoms of men shall outlast
you fain gorn
my friend the definitive event of the
early fourth age
is the coronation of aragorn as a ruler
of
gondor and arnor let us together rebuild
this world
that we may share in the days of peace
the name elessar the new king becomes
protector of a huge portion of middle
earth
and proceeds to rule over his new realm
for an incredible 120 years
during this time he declares the shire a
free region under his protection
and gives most of sauromon's former
domain to the ants
aragorn also makes his steward faramir
the prince of ethilian
faramir becomes one of aragorn's chief
generals and in a letter later in life
tolkien
even explained that the king made
ferramir the lead counselor of his chief
advisory group known as the great
council
of gondor aragorn also remains close
with eomer
who rules as the king of rohan for 65
years
these brothers at heart renew the oath
of aorl
swearing to come to one another's aid
when needed in the return of the king
tolkien writes
that they fight together often because
for those sauron
has passed the hatreds and evils that he
bred had not
died and the king of the west had many
enemies to subdue
aragorn and arwen marry just before the
beginning of the fourth age
they proceed to rule happily for over a
century
and the queen gives birth to a son named
eldarian
and a number of daughters 120 years into
the fourth age at the ripe old age of
210 years old king alisar
finally dies however he doesn't pass in
his sleep
nor is he killed in battle instead
aragorn willingly gives up his spirit
before he becomes old
and broken it is also explained that
after aragorn's death
arlen went forth from the house and the
light of her eyes was quenched
and it seemed to her people that she had
become cold and gray
as nightfall and winter that comes
without a star the queen then bids
farewell to her children
and travels to la florian all of the
elves have left the golden wood by this
point but she wanders through the empty
land nonetheless
eventually she lies down to rest in the
same spot where she and aragorn had
become
engaged long before there she quietly
dies
and it's said that her green grave will
remain until the world
is changed in gondor eldarian becomes
king
and in a letter written in 1972 tolkien
briefly mentioned that his reign lasts
for roughly
a century i thought i'd die fighting
side by side with a mouth
what about side by side with a friend
after sauron is defeated and the war of
the ring comes to an
end lego lost and gimli stay pretty busy
on their way home from war
these newfound friends first visit the
ensign veingorn and then
aglarond the glittering caves hidden
behind homes deep
afterwards gimli returns to the lonely
mountain
only to find that the war of the ring
has devastated the whole region
eventually he gathers some of his fellow
dwarf folk
and they settle down in aglarond kimley
himself leads the dwarven colony
becoming the lord of the glittering
caves
this relocation puts gimli close to
ministerith
and the return of the king states he and
his people did great works
in gondor and rohan of particular note
they fixed the gates of ministerith
which the witch king's army had smashed
forging the replacement parts out of
steel
and mithril lego lost does his part to
back up aragorn's fledgling new kingdom
too
and brings elves from merkwood to settle
an ethylene
after aragorn dies however lego loss
finally follows the calling of his kind
and takes a ship across the sea for
valinor interestingly
tolkien claims that because of their
one-of-a-kind friendship
gemly is also given permission to travel
with his elven friend to the
otherworldly realm
the shire remains a bustling center of
rural activity during the fourth age
and sam mary and pippin are at the heart
of the action
sam and rose have 13 children and their
daughter goldilocks ends up marrying
pippin's son ferramir sam and harris
begin finishes writing the red book that
bilbo and frodo had worked on
and has elected the mayor of the shire's
unofficial capital
michael delving for seven consecutive
terms pippin remains a knight of gondor
and also becomes the took and thane both
important leadership positions in his
family
and the shire respectively mary becomes
the master of buckland
a small colony settled long before by
his family just outside of the borders
of the shire eventually rose dies and
legend states that sam
the last of the ring bears actually
follows his master west to the undying
lance
a couple of years later the elderly mary
and pippin leave the shire
and head south they eventually die in
gondor where they are laid to rest next
to aragorn
details regarding the fourth age are
hard to come by
especially after the first couple of
centuries however it seems clear that by
this point in the timeline the age of
men has truly dawned the first and
second ages had been dominated by the
elves and the dwarfs while the third age
had seen men
slowly rise to prominence by the fourth
age however the
elves and dwarves are clearly on the way
out and men
are on the up and up in the prologue to
the fellowship of the ring it's
explained that some of the high elven
folk remain
in middle earth for a time led by
elrond's sons and eventually joined by
galadriel's husband keleborn
while it isn't known when keleborn
finally sails to the blessed realm
when he does go he takes with him the
last living memory
of the outer days and middle-earth the
dwarves remain in middle-earth however
and judging from gambling's colonization
efforts even appear to expand their
dominions for a time
nevertheless they do slowly drift out of
sight out of mind
and eventually right out of
middle-earth's history
aside from the lord of the rings and the
hobbit most of the middle-earth material
that we have today
was published by j.r.r tolkien's son
christopher tolkien
after his father's death this wasn't for
the elder tolkien's lack of dedication
to his
world though it was more the result of a
deep set perfectionism that held the
great author back from publishing much
other material nevertheless tolkien did
try to publish more middle earth stories
during his lifetime
including a sequel to the lord of the
rings called the new shadow the story
appeared to be set a century or so
after aragorn's death placing it well
into the fourth age
the concept toyed with a resurgence of
evil and middle earth long after the
events of the word of the ring had
become
ancient history however tolkien never
got more than a handful of pages into
the story before he gave up in a letter
written in 1964
he referred to the project as both
sinister and depressing adding that it
had the making of a thriller
but that it was alas simply not worth
doing
tolkien's letters are an important
source of information for fans of middle
earth
as the author used them to reveal more
about middle earth long and complex
history
in one of those letters the author
provides a hint as to when he personally
believed the fourth age ended or at
least how it fits
into the world's larger history in this
letter tolkien points out that he
imagines the 20th century to exist
roughly 6 000 years after the third age
he initially states that this could put
us somewhere around the end of the fifth
age judging from the approximate lengths
of the second and third ages
however he also clarifies they have i
think quickened and i
imagine we are actually at the end of
the sixth age or in the seventh
while nobody can be sure the exact
timeline of the fourth age
it is clear that at one point the future
of tolkien's world becomes the distant
past
of our own check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
lord of the rings are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]